I am not a destroyer of companies.
I am a liberator up them.
The point is,
ladies and gentlemen at Gree,
for lack of a better word,
is good.
Greed is right.
Greed works.
Greed clarifies,
cuts through and captures.
Yes,
I think evolutionary spirit in all of
its forms,
we'd for life,
for money,
for love.
Knowledge has mark upward search of
mankind in green.
You mark my words will not only save
till dark paper,
but that other malfunctioning
corporation called the USA.
Thank you very much.
Despite this famous speech from Oliver
Stone's Wallstreet,
extolling the virtues of greed,
excess and capitalist,
no one could ever accuse stone or the
film itself of doing the same thing.
Indeed,
it's because of Gordon Gekkos sermon
that we know the opposite is true.
If we're all greedy,
we can win together.
That's the essence of Geckos message.
Of course,
oliver stone and the rest of us know
that in a connected capitalist society,
greed always works at the expense of
others and when later in the film we
watch Bud Fox learn how Gecko plan to
gain at the expense of his father.
The moral hypocrisy of Gecko and the
film central condemnation of capitalists
excess is laid bare,
but that was then,
and this
I think I was asked,
is the omen.
I keep it on it like the Romans three
pitches where the child is.
We live in the moment
26 years after Oliver Stone Wall Street,
Martin Scorsese gives us the wolf of
Wall Street.
Compare Gordon Gekkos moral defense of
excess with these comments made by
Scorsese's protagonists.
Jordan Belfort,
I was selling garbage to garbage men and
making cash hand over fist,
so I was selling them shit.
The way I looked at it,
their money was better off in my pocket.
I knew how to spend it better for unlike
Gecko,
makes no moral argument for his great.
He knows what he's doing is wrong.
He does it anyway.
There no great tragedy haunting his
steps like the downfall of Gordon Gekko
or the extreme paranoia and eventual
disappearance of one of Scorsese's other
great protagonists,
Henry Hill from goodfellas.
Belfour does go to prison for a short
time,
but as he soon discovers,
see for a brief fleeting moment,
I'd forgotten I was rich and I lived in
a place where everything was for sale
for its crimes are met with minimal
punishment,
both physical and psychological,
and just to twist the knife on that
fact,
scorsese has the man himself,
the actual Jordan Belfort,
introduces character as
single,
baddest motherfucker I have ever met,
so maybe it's no surprise that the wolf
of Wall Street was raked through the mud
by a number of critics for glorifying
apologizing,
endorsing capitalists.
Excess Scorsese's film certainly doesn't
offer the negative critique of tragedies
like Wall Street or goodfellas.
It doesn't even offer a satirical
critique of late capitalism such as you
might see in films like American Psycho,
where Patrick Bateman's smooth,
almost enlightened exterior is
undermined by his psychopathy,
self-loathing and psychological
breakdown.
A satirical critique of capitalism would
require the movie itself in its tone and
themes to ridicule or expose the
improper behavior it displays,
but the wolf of Wall Street gives us no
such thing.
The joke is never on Jordan Belfort.
It's on everyone else,
his wife,
his friends,
his enemies and the world at large.
We're not made aware of some unknown
underwriting.
Sadness,
quite the opposite.
Belfort is perfectly disaffected by the
scummy ways he makes his money and the
debauchery lifestyle he spends it on.
His personal philosophy,
echoes that of alien from harmony,
corrine's spring breakers.
Some people,
they want to do the right thing.
Doing the wrong thing was always telling
me,
no,
you've got to change.
I'm about and change stack and change as
it money.
Both films are prime examples of what
film critic is he black has called the
new cinema of excess films in which
greed and excess are explored,
but never for a moment condemned.
Indeed.
A key feature of this kind of cinema is
that the film itself partakes in the
excess.
It shows nowhere is this more clear than
in Wolf,
which runs for three hours and moves
from montage too.
Montage in ever crazier flights of
hedonism,
but just because Scorsese refuses to
condemn bail for it doesn't mean that
he's by extension endorsing him.
Either.
Excess is excess.
It's exhausting.
It's too much,
too fast.
Scorsese has no illusions about this.
His extensive use of closeup reveals the
vulgarity of this way of living is
montage is exhaust rather than glamorize
the hedonism two,
which were privy is less attractive than
disorienting,
less desirable than
well will not die sober,
get don't fuck.
Walls.
Street
is a descriptive project learning from
its moralizing predecessors,
even the predecessors in Scorsese's own
filmography.
There were no bud Fox is to take down
the Gordon Gekkos of the eighties.
There wasn't even any one to take down
Belfort's elk in the nineties.
The folly of late capitalism got worse
and worse,
not hitting its lowest point until 2008
in the financial recession,
and it's unclear despite new
regulations,
if any of those lessons were really
taken to heart.
The reason for this is because the
excesses of Jordan Belfort are our
excess.
It's like him were to enlightened not to
know the expenses,
which are gazillion products are made
like him.
We don't really make an attempt at
moralizing away.
Our involvement in that system.
We just don't care to discuss.
We feel for Belfort is hypocritical.
The indignation we inflict on him is
less a righteous act than a self
righteous dilution.
Scorsese refuses to participate in that
delusion anymore,
and the result is a film so
unapologetically excessive that the
audience might finally realized that the
screen they thought they were watching
was
in fact a camera.